[Música]
y como lo adelantamos con nuestro primer
invitado al día vamos a hablar de los
ganadores del premio nobel de economía
que fue para los economistas david carr
howard y en west y guido w inventó según
la academia sueca los ganadores han
contribuido a responder muchas de las
grandes preguntas de la sociedad gracias
a su método que se utiliza para las
situaciones que surgen en la vida real
para así proporcionar nuevos
conocimientos sobre el mercado laboral
para ello quiero saludar entonces a
gustavo neffa él es el director de
research for traders también economista
y profesor de finanzas gustavo gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa en france 24 muy buen día cuáles
son estas contribuciones para el mercado
laboral de estos ganadores del premio
nobel 2021 de economía
bueno muy buenos días las contribuciones
han sido de un mercado laboral que ha
sufrido
realmente unos cambios enormes como
consecuencia de la pandemia pero me
gustaría revisar un poco la importancia
de un premio nobel en esta circunstancia
que ha sido compartido y ha sido
compartido en muchos años a lo largo de
su historia recordemos que existen
premios nobeles desde los años 1900 1 en
cinco categorías dos categorías blandas
como literatura y paz y tres más de
ciencias duras como física química
medicina este premio nobel ha sido
instaurado en 1968 como parte de una
obra de contribuciones a la humanidad el
mundo está necesitando este tipo de
contribuciones para de reflejar la
productividad por un lado el aumento de
productividad por un lado pero por otro
lado las deficiencias en las modalidades
de contratación los marcos laborales han
estado sujeto a mucho estrés durante
este último tiempo y la contribución de
estos galardonados ha sido evidentemente
puesta sobre la evidencia empírica a lo
largo de este último año y medio
recordemos que el año pasado los premios
habían sido entregados dos personas que
hicieron contribuciones sobre temas de
licitaciones con aplicaciones prácticas
bueno este año le ha tocado también a la
real academia de ciencias de suecia que
tiene una tarea titánica porque entre
250 y 300
especialistas son seleccionados de una
muestra de unas 3.000 personas por parte
de un comité como para poder analizar
sus contribuciones a la economía real
ahora habrá gustado cuáles son estas
aplicaciones reales y tangibles de estas
investigaciones de estos ganadores de
2021 del premio nobel de economía
bueno el mercado laboral en su esencia
se encuentra en un proceso de conversión
y los aportes que han hecho se basan
justamente en la mejora en la
contribución de la ciencia respecto a la
modalidad de contratación hemos visto un
mundo cambiante en donde estas
contribuciones ayudan a un mejor
entendimiento de lo que está ocurriendo
en estos momentos es necesario más de
estas contribuciones como para entender
el mundo que se viene pospandemia en
donde ha dejado secuelas no sólo en el
mercado laboral sino también en los
niveles de deuda y los niveles del
déficit fiscal de las economías y sobre
todo en lo social que sirve en la
dinámica de interacción entre las
personas creo que muchos más de estas
contribuciones vendrán hacia adelante y
recordemos que recién en 1908 se
instaura este premio nobel es un premio
auspiciado por banco de suecia que viene
a ser el sexto premio nobel y en su
esencia eran cinco damas por lo cual
tenemos mucho más como para disfrutar de
todas estas contribuciones y esos
galardones tiene que ser puesto en orden
en mérito son la base en su aplicación
práctica es decir sobre la base de cómo
las empresas pueden contratar a los
trabajadores de ahora en adelante de una
mejor manera está atendiendo los
problemas de competitividad de
competencia entre las compañías y esta
nueva modalidad de trabajo remoto y
también lo habla ajustado en un mundo
tan cambiante
postpandemia donde pues evidentemente
los ingresos de muchísimas personas se
mermaron el año pasado como esto puede
cambiar entonces la forma en la que se
determinan los salarios mínimos por
ejemplo
bueno hay una teoría obviamente de un
salario mínimo más alto para poder
contribuir a aquellas personas que
cayeron la pobreza aquellas personas que
sienten la desigualdad de ingreso dentro
de las economías pero recordemos que
salarios mínimo más alto no significa
eliminar la pobreza en muchas economías
de latinoamérica y fíjense el caso de
brasil con más de 10 por ciento de
inflación va a ir descendiendo pero
sobre la base de un incremento de la
tasa de interés de argentina que lucha
por la tasa de inflación del 51% que
probablemente esté en torno al 49 por
ciento este año y posiblemente en torno
al 45 por ciento al año que viene y
muchas otras economías que han visto
este incremento de los precios a base de
cuellos de botella el incremento del
precio petróleo por arriba de 80 dólares
en los mercados internacionales para el
precio del doblete y sobre todo
restricciones de oferta como
consecuencia de la pandemia one todo
esto contribuye obviamente a que el
salario sea una de las variables de
ajuste y precisamente por eso el desafío
está en las economías en poder otorgar
las condiciones para que las empresas
privadas desarrollarse de la mejor
manera el estado presente contribuye de
manera transitoria y de manera
estructural puede producir un daño a
largo plazo por los niveles de deuda y
sobre todo la inflación que en
latinoamérica obviamente conocemos
perfectamente sus consecuencias ahora
gustavo le quiero preguntar hacia dónde
va la economía mundial en un futuro
cercano con toda esta pues pandemia
obviamente que nos ha afectado y pues se
replanteó todo el orden pues económico y
social de las personas además le quiero
preguntar si ya la economía pues se está
estudiando como una ciencia muchísimo
más social de lo que era antes
claro están las ramas duras y recordemos
que el 11 de chicago y muchos del
alumnado de este premio nobel que
estamos hablando hace poco obviamente
dieron lugar a otro tipo de estudios con
más injerencia en lo social la economía
es una ciencia social en su esencia pero
obviamente uno se la pasa en la
universidad con muchas fórmulas
matemáticas que pues no aplica el mundo
ha cambiado muchísimo bueno hacia dónde
va el mundo bueno creo que el mundo por
pandemia es un mundo diferente en lo
laboral justamente que veníamos tratando
tema recién pero sobre todo en las
interacciones de los países china ha
quedado conformado a nivel geopolítico
como aquel país que quiere obviamente
detener la
supremacía a nivel económico y
obviamente eeuu que lo tiene y lo
refuerza así con un dólar un poco más
fuerte este año con su supremacía no
sólo militar sino geopolítica y sobre
todo económica y donde se ha visto más
allá de la habilidad del dólar del año
pasado la fortaleza de este año se sigue
siendo el dólar la moneda que tendría
que tener la economía mundial sobre la
base de el comercio y las transacciones
la aplicación de precios en los mercados
de commodities y de otras referencias
que lo hacen todavía detener la moneda
que es la más fuerte en el mundo la
supremacía mundial viene forjada por el
g2 sí pero hay que 10 va a tener una
interacción muy grande a partir de ahora
sólo a base de alinearse de un lado del
otro pero sobre todo de contribuir en lo
económico como para reducir el nivel de
pobreza
el déficit fiscal de niveles de
endeudamiento que han hipotecado
muchísimas generaciones en este último
tiempo los niveles de deuda en relación
al pib se han incrementado de manera
exponencial bueno el gran desafío del
mundo es generar el crecimiento
destinado a puede reparar esas deudas